good afternoon thank you for being here
my name is Mitchell moutarde I'm a
politics major here at Hillsdale College
but the man of the hour is dr. Fleming
he is a fairchild professor of
literature emeritus at Princeton
University where he taught for 40 years
he's a graduate of the University of the
South he was a Rhodes Scholar at Oxford
and earned his PhD at Princeton
University he is a former president of
the medieval Academy of America and a
fellow of the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences as well as the American
Philosophical Foundation Society excuse
me
he is written on English French and
Latin literature of the Middle Ages on
the continuity of the classical
tradition and on the cultural
contributions of Christian asceticism he
is the author of numerous books
including the dark side of the
Enlightenment Wizards alchemists and
spiritual seekers in the age of reason
and the anti-communist manifestos for
books that shape the Cold War please
help me in welcoming dr. Fleming
[Applause]
thank you very much for that generous
introduction
which no doubt leaves my audience
wondering what in the world I'm doing at
this conference I want to point out the
aesthetic dimensions of modern communism
that's a joke you don't need to laugh
but you could at least smile arthur
Kessler's darkness at noon a short
historical novel first published in
English in 1940 and much more
importantly published again in French in
1945 is one of the classics of 20th
century literature but I remember that
Mark Twain defined a classic as a book
that everybody wants to have read but
nobody wants to read I do hope that
everybody in this room has read it but
that's a hope not an assumption so I'll
begin with a plot summary this can be
brief because practically nothing
happens there is the year as 1938
there's this Russian man rubbish off a
hero among the Bolsheviks who seized
power 20 years ago he's had an important
career as a communist agent in Germany
and later in the Politburo in Moscow but
as the book begins root Mushaf is being
incarcerated for daeviation ism a
political heresy and a capital crime
everybody knows from the start
especially rubbish awful but the whole
purpose of the incarceration is to
consider secure his confession to the
vague but absurd crimes of which he is
accused so that he may be legally
executed the physical setting of the
book which the reader must share with
the prisoner is a cramped and
claustrophobic jail cell with a small
window in the door briefly unshut 'red
at feeding times this peephole or Judith
offers occasional and constricted
glimpses
of activity in the corridor while the
author relieves the claustrophobic
claustrophobia in two other ways there
are three important episodes of
flashback in which we enter the
prisoner's meditation on three of his
personal experiences earlier in the 30s
one relates to Hitler's crushing of the
German Communist Party one to Stalin's
foreign policy with regard to Mussolini
and one to his own lethal betrayal of
his lover in Moscow these episodes are
crucial to of crucial thematic relevance
of course but the books philosophical
heart is in the visceral sense dialogic
rubra Shah is taken from his cell for a
series of interrogations surely the
greatest good-cop bad-cop sequence in
world literature which have all the
depths as well as the clear intimations
of the structure of platonic dialogue
eventually rubus off confesses to the
imaginary crimes it is your job reader
to figure out the why of it an NKVD
agent leads rubbish off to the basement
of the prison then shoots him
point-blank in the base of his skull and
the rubbish off end of novel and though
I cannot say end of communism important
and post-war France I'm tempted to say
the beginning of the end despite the
political enthusiasms of many of my
fellow professors the literature very
few works of fiction actually have had a
significant political and historical
repercussions Uncle Tom's Cabin may be
darkness at noon
definitely but why France after all
darkness at noon was written in German
and first published in English it's a
quite complex story that involves among
other things the fascination of European
intellectuals with communism in the
interwar years the virtual destruction
of the germ
Communist Party in 1933 the Spanish
Civil War of 1936 to 39 as reality and
as myth the Moscow purged trials of 1936
to 38 the Hitler Stalin pact in 1939 and
the transition of the Second World War
from its phoney phase to its decidedly
unfabulous in France in 1940 I cannot so
much as touch upon all these things in
40 minutes
but they are both in and behind
Kessler's novel darkness at noon is
actually part of a trilogy though it has
so far outdistanced its two partners in
fame that many people don't even know
their names the gladiators and arrival
and departure should you want to join
the happy few Kessler explicitly tells
us that the theme of the tragedy of the
trilogy is the relationship between
means and ends sometimes spoken of in
terms of omelets and egg breaking as in
a favorite saw of william durante known
in his day as Stalin's man at the New
York Times this was a problem that all
of us must face in our ethical and
political lives it certainly was a
problem for Western communists many of
whom were idealists of the most
aspirational and therefore the most
dangerous kind listen to what Whittaker
Chambers whose conversion was effected
by a little pamphlet of Lenin's a Soviet
at work says here Pierre writes chambers
was the simple statement the terror and
dictatorship are justified to defend the
socialist revolution if socialism is
justified terror is an instrument of
socialist policy now Arthur Kessler one
of the major literary intellectuals of
the last century Toni jut actually
devoted essay to him under the title and
exempt three intellectual was born in
1905
while still in his 20s he'd moved on
from one all demanding enthusiasm
Zionism to a second communism he was a
covert member of the German Communist
Party living and travelling freely under
the cover of a profession at what she
excelled that of a liberal left
journalist he was in the Ukraine in 1932
to see the broken eggs is the hole in
the door that is the state imposed
famine that was Stalin's policy for the
collectivization of Agriculture he
witnessed hits Hitler's rise to power
and the brutal destruction of the German
Communist Party like many other German
communists he found refuge abroad in
England and France primarily unless one
wants to call imprisonment in Spain
refuge it was as an exile that he
distantly viewed the famous purge trials
of the second half of the decade one
needs to recall to mind what that phrase
the purge trials actually means in a
period of about five or six years the
Stalin apparatus destroyed all the
veteran Bolsheviks we had been prominent
during Lenin's reign more than half the
delegates to the 1934 Communist Party
Congress much of the top brass in the
Red Army and three-quarters of the
sitting members of the Central Committee
of the Communist Party this was not
minor surgery it fluttered the Dove cuts
of even the truest of true believers
Kessler's second best-known piece of
writing is probably his essay in the God
that failed a collection of essays first
published in 1949 by eminent apostates
from communism in it he and several
others analyzed the commitment of the
1930s intellectual to communism in terms
of its quasi or pseudo religious
character disquieting root world events
now brought down upon Kessler and
agonizing crisis of faith
it was in this context he would
undertake the writing of his famous
novel
Kessler's official letter of resignation
from the German Communist Party is dated
April 22nd 1938 that is scarcely a month
after the completion of the Moscow trial
of the so called block of rightists and
Trotskyists often called the Bou current
trial because of its most famous victim
Nikolai Bukharin
in my book I pointed out I think
convincingly that Kessler actually
incorporated parts of the transcript of
that trial as well as a death house
interview supposedly given by Bukhari
into darkness at noon we may safely
conclude that the Moscow trials were a
significant factor in his break with the
party as they were with so many others
most people will tell you that the purge
trials or what darkness at noon is all
about but for Kessler there was another
and much more personal connection his
own experiences in the Spanish Civil War
he'd been in a nationalist jail under
sentence of death the seriousness of
which he had no reason to doubt he'd
heard the confused sound of clanking
doors and dragging feet as fellow
prisoners were led out to be shot the
awful immediacy of the fictional Rubik
offs experience with his own lived
reality and he had come to believe that
the communist role in the war with Spain
was not a blunder of military strategy
but a purposely hypocritical sharad of
Stalin's foreign policy he did not have
to wait for disillusionment as so many
of his comrades did for the Hitler
Stalin pact of August 1939 now the
chronology is confused and some degree
contested but we think he was already
working on this book or at least
planning it in 1938 he'd certainly made
a beginning in the
three more months of 1939 during that
time he hooked up I believe that is the
current term of art with a young British
artist
Daphne Hardy and they set up house in
the South of France and the Albert Mehra
team he spent his days writing she
sculpting this able young woman was
fluent in both German and French having
had part of her early education in both
tongues kestler himself was a polyglot
but as yet the only language he wrote
with full confidence was German the plan
had probably been to publish the book in
French but world events intruded by
September 1939 Germany and France were
in a state of war with the French
Communist Party
so recently rabid in its hostility to
Nazis and to all fascias now silent and
docile under the thumb of the fewers new
best friend Comrade Stalin the situation
moved beyond the surreal when the phony
war turned real with the devastating
German blitzkrieg invasion of France in
May 1940 the collapse of the French army
and the amazingly Swift German
occupation of the north of France and
its establishment of a French puppet
regime in the south with Vichy as its
capital the head of the French Communist
Party showed his true tri colors by
fleeing to Moscow the whole of France
was crawling with persecuted German
refugees from Nazism quite a few of them
including Kessler himself both
Communists and Jews in the South were
many of the defeated anti-fascists who
had fled north from Spain so of keepo
this is the tragic background to
Casper's book called scum of the earth
now seeing the way the wind was blowing
in the late 1939 Kessler had shifted
plans obviously he could not publish his
book in France it would have to be in
England he and Daphne returned to Paris
he worked hard at the manuscript
Daphne Hardy's new assignment was to
translate his German pages into English
her native tongue this she did quite
brilliantly considering that she had no
special expertise as a good awry
translator
let alone a familiarity with German
Marxist jargon and German tribunal
legalese both of which were obviously
prominent in kissters original
composition I lacked the leisure to tell
you the hair-raising details of Hardy's
solitary flight to England in June of
1940 is it precious manuscript in her
carpetbag metaphorical bloodhounds being
at her back but she caught the famous
last ship to Britain more or less the
maritime equivalent of the last
helicopter out of Saigon and delivered
her cargo to the eerily awaiting English
publisher Jonathan Cape he published
darkness of noon at the end of 1940 that
was the good news the bad news was that
at the end of 1940 most people in
Britain were preoccupied with issues
other than the latest novel or even
Marxist deviation ISM there was the
small matter of national survival in
England darkness at noon made about his
biggest splash in the week of the Battle
of Britain as a cobblestone tossed into
a gale currency it did considerably
better in America still largely aloof
from the European war and it was
destined to do better yet five years
later in post-war France the site of its
spectacular political influence and the
venue to which we must transfer
ourselves for the remainder of this
brief lecture to say that France emerged
from the second world war with the
bruise de psyche is a necessary
understatement in 1940 the country's
army had collapsed in ten days literally
millions of its citizens had acquiesced
in the semi fascist arrangements of the
Vichy
thousands of others had quite actively
collaborated with the Nazis and shameful
activities including their anti-semitic
purges in a thousand different
localities in long war and long
occupation created scores and
resentments that now cried out to be
settled or revenged
nobody revels in oppression but there
can be resentment too in recognizing the
necessity to be saved
especially when the love could be so
tough at the beginning of the war the
British had sunk part of the French
fleet in North Africa with large loss of
life West the ships fall into Nazi hands
by the later stages of the war both
Churchill and Roosevelt and especially
the latter had come to regard Charles
DeGaulle
is a vainglorious pest an attitude of
which the general was aware to this very
day few aspects of the history of
European war are more delicate than the
question of the French Resistance
there was one of course and it produced
some feats of great bravery and
significant military action but it's
actual size effectiveness in composition
have been the matter of myth making at
least since 1945 what concerns us here
are the beliefs of French intellectuals
in the immediate post-war period many of
the resistance were communists and the
Communist Party organisation in
discipline often did give operational
coherence to resistance activities the
party emerged from the war with a
greatly augmented national and patriotic
prestige in the propaganda battles two
ideas emerged victorious the first was
that communism through the agency of the
Red Army had destroyed the Nazis the
second was that the resistance had been
to all effective purposes the military
wing of the French Communist Party party
Libre
leaders claimed with concer bULOG
saturation that 75,000 of their members
had been executed by the Nazis communism
was in fact the essence of French
patriotism this was an extraordinary
reversal Maurice Torres the French
Communist leader who had to flee an
ignominy to Moscow during the period of
the Hitler Stalin pact now returned as
the deputy leader of the country but
things looked somewhat different in
retrospect to but to many sober
observers in late 1945 it seemed
entirely possible that both Italy and
France would go communist through the
legal electoral legal electoral means
this was the France to which Arthur
Koestler now returned now Jewish
publishing houses in Paris had of course
been shut down during the German
occupation one of those now seeking
Tibet get back in the game
was Kell Kalman lavey the house of
Kalman wavy whose principal director had
known and admired Kessler before the war
and who now sought to put together a
vist that would include something by him
this suited Kessler just fine as he
longed to return to Paris still regarded
by most intellectuals as the cultural
capital of the world publisher and
author were destined to become intimate
friends darkness at noon had not been
forgotten in France because one cannot
forget what one is never known the book
had been published only in England in
America and only in English kestler had
long since lost the original German
manuscript and one of the ironies of
this international bestseller is that
the hundreds of thousands of copies in
many of the world's principal languages
would all derive from Daphne Hardy's
English understanding the extraordinary
impact of the publication of the French
version of the book
in Paris at the end of 1945 must bring
us back to some of its principal themes
I don't know what the title darkness at
noon means and there's a noise people
who thinks it is an expert I hadn't know
at least that much I'm absolutely open
to persuasion should any of you have
good ideas so far as I know kiss for
himself only said that the title sounded
good yes indeed but Kelman lady didn't
know what it meant the title meant
either so he gave it a better one the
French title is the zero L Anthony zero
and infinity
nothing and everything now the prisoner
rubbish off has two interrogators even
off the nice cop a one-time friend and a
man of shared cultivated social
background from the old intelligentsia
and glutton bad cop a harsh Soviet new
man or in rubra chef's mind one of the
new Neanderthal errs the two
investigators are both more considerable
philosophers then one usually expects to
find at the local precinct headquarters
it is they who in the course of their
attempts to elicit rubbish oft
confession articulate an explicit
language
Kessler's principal themes even off is
nearly aphoristic i quote there are only
two conceptions of human ethics and they
are at opposite poles one of them is
Christian and humane declares the
individual to be sacrosanct and asserts
that the rules of arithmetic are not to
be applied to human units the other
starts from the basic principle that a
collective aim justifies all means and
not only allows but demands that the
individual should in every way be
subordinate
and sacrificed to the community which
may dispose of it as an experimentation
rabbit or a sacrificial lamb we learned
that this principle has been admirably
exemplified when the sentimental even
off is shot for his failure to break the
prisoner that honor goes to the brutal
glutton in the final section of the book
called the grammatical fiction the
exhausted and nearly indifferent
prisoner has at last confesses to
everything to the specific but
unspecified fictional crimes for which
he's been indicted to a comprehensive
counter-revolutionary attitude to
framing his lover orlova to cover up his
own crimes the grammatical fiction of
course is the first-person pronoun the
word that in European languages gives us
distinctive identification to anyone who
speaks or writes I should yes yo yo
a go this word is void of ethical
significance according to the Marxist
dialectic by which Ruby Shah has lived
and now will die now many of the most
prominent public intellectuals in France
were open members of the Communist Party
practically all the rest were avowed
socialists their view of the Soviet
Union was perhaps slightly more
sophisticated than that of the rank and
file vast hydroelectric dams the giant
iron crucibles of the magnetic mountain
determined young men at arms trampling
on swastikas no-nonsense women on truck
tractors goggled aviators smiling into
the Sun but it was hardly more realistic
or less hagiographic the 0el anthony
hardly accorded with this view as he
began to write his novel Kessler had
been an ex communist but not an
anti-communist
that's a crucial distinction in his
letter of resignation from the party he
had written the existence of the Soviet
Union is a decisively positive factor in
the political balance of our time
and nothing is further from my mind than
to abandon that conviction but that was
then
before the Hitler Stalin pact before the
old hot war and the new Cold War the
European left might have thought that it
has had assigned to historical oblivion
such a disquieting episodes as the
Moscow trials the murder of Leon Trotsky
or the early rumors of slave labor camps
and the paradise of the workers now
burst onto the scene an extraordinary
historical novel that would not let the
dead past stay dead now this lecture is
mainly bibliographical history but I
must insist on one literary critical
point it's this darkness at noon is a
novel that is a work of imaginative
fiction Kessler wrote in a preparatory
note quote the characters in this book
are fictitious the historical
circumstances which determined their
action are real the life of the man and
as rubbish off is a synthesis of the
lives of a number of men who were
victims to the so-called Moscow trials
several of them were personally known to
the author this book is dedicated to
their memory now I must insist on this
point because so few others have I
believe I read every important
contemporary French language review or
analysis of the book of which there were
dozens and I found only one in the
newspaper of the Figaro that treated it
as a novel rather than as a political
polemic still even as a novel the book
asked a terrible question of all
Frenchmen
is this really the sole system in which
we are to find our national
survival and our destiny in 2001 a
professional bibliography and
frantz.martin pool and published a lurid
paper entitled a cold war bestseller the
reaction to arthur Kessler's darkness at
noon in France 1940 1945 she estimates
that in those five years about 300,000
copies of the book were sold and that
for each book that were probably by
conservative estimate ten readers Kelman
levy had hit the jackpot that's an
impressive sales record by any standards
but it becomes absolutely extraordinary
when we take into consideration the
protracted paper shortage in post-war
France the publisher had very restricted
amounts of printing stock until at least
1948 they were able to reprint in only
an arbitrary or opportunistic manner
successive early runs an initial 20,000
then 44,000 more than 30,000 more sold
out in short order
sometimes in a single day secondhand
copies of Lazaro became a hot item in
the black market
commanding sums for an exact excess of
the publishers list price
now everybody at least everybody who
mattered in cultural circles wanted to
get a hold of the book that it was anti
something was obvious to everybody
though at first the Communists didn't
seem to be sure just quite what it was
Auntie Kessler who was now in Paris and
often behaving outrageously helped them
along by publishing an exacting on
ambiguous attacks on Stalinism and on
such philosophical masterpiece and such
philosophical masterpieces as the yogi
and the commissar he openly attacked the
stalingrad syndrome which was the quasi
mystical belief that the russian war
successes
stem directly from the universal love of
its citizens towards socialism rather
than from actual material military
realities Kessler attracted all the best
enemies there was no respectable or
effective French right in those days but
there was an important center best
represented in my opinion by the great
Ramone our own author of the classic the
opium of the intellectuals I had a
surprisingly large anti-communist left
almost waiting for something to rally
around that something turned out to be
the polemic over darkness at noon in my
book the anti-communist manifestos I
examined kessler's interactions with the
Paris intellectuals with a comparative
leisure which the format this format
does not allow me the iconic
intellectual of the period and perhaps
of 20th century France altogether was
Jean Paul Sartre Sartre and his
companion Simone de Beauvoir presided
over the choices Salone in the capital
and Kessler immediately set out to
attach himself to it Sartre was not a
communist he was not even at this period
the hardcore fellow-traveller he would
later become indeed French communists
frequently abused him but he held and
acted upon several of the left-wing
dogmas the customers book was likely to
disturb though he was not a systematic
Marxist he expressed many familiar
Marxist ideas in familiar Marxist
language
these included the absolute necessity of
socialism achieved through violent
revolution by and in the name of the
working class or the proletariat the
Soviet Union was the one place on earth
for the socialist revolution
occurred in however infantile or
unfinished the form and the Soviet Union
must be protected and nourished the
Soviet Union was on the side of history
the side of the future antique communism
might pretend to address certain in
felicities and aberrations of the Stalin
regime but it was at bottom an attack on
socialism itself and as such
inadmissible Sartre was in short a prime
example of a political type of the
mid-century that needs further study the
type of the anti anti-communist every
anti-communist is a dog is one of his
well-known pronouncements it was
inevitable that he and Kessler could not
permanently remain friends Kessler's
bibulous one-night stand with Simone de
Beauvoir was also perhaps unhelpful in
this regard anti-communism was not the
was the issue over which Sartre and pest
allure would definitely split but the
split itself simply amplified Kessler's
intellectual prestige the great Sartre
after all split only with the famous and
the influential probably of greater
significance to the political debate
about communism among Parisian
intellectuals was Kessler's in it was
Kessler's book war with the philosopher
maurice merleau-ponty author of humanism
and terror 1947 and another Sartre
splitter this went to the very heart of
the question of ends and means Mello
county's claim that he had no interest
in trying to defend the Moscow trials
bemused many readers as did judgments
such as the following quote within the
USSR violence and deception have
official status while humanity is to be
found in day
life on the contrary in democracies the
principles are humane but deception and
violence rule daily life there were at
least a dozen book clanks attack on the
zero often including personal abuse
toward its author from official
communist sources it became increasingly
obvious they were preaching to the choir
in this debate
the historical setting of Kessler's
masterpiece was a huge advantage to the
anti-communist in the 1930s true
believers in the West could still
swallow the explanation that the
defendants were quite simply guilty by
the 1940s the strategy of choice had
evolved to a high-minded oblivion of
what significance are these minor
episodes of ancient history in a world
in which the Soviet Union has defeated
fascism only to see it arising anew and
with greater malevolence for by now the
zenith doctrine which held that a new
war between the democracies and the
imperialists was both inevitable and
proximate was the official Stalinist
line but readers of Lazaro really were
interested in comrade Ruben off and
everything about him his musings his
diary his vignettes of revolutionary
history his pants nay glasses his
nagging toothache above all they were
interested in flying in the world such a
man would without the application of
unendurable physical pain narcotics
hypnotism or other physical duress why
would such a person falsely claimed to
have performed criminally capital
he knows full well he never performed
and quite probably never could have
performed and fly had those real
historical old Bolsheviks in 1936 and
1938 the men whose actual lives
according to the novelists preparatory
note were synthesized in Ruby shafts
fictional life why had they done so
before him
careful readers found an answer to this
puzzling historical question in
Kessler's historical novel there's a
certain amount of religious language and
even scriptural allusions in darkness it
named though Kestner was a Jew as was
his creature rubbish off a subtle but
significant narrative detail textually
visible only to the sharp-eyed the
illusions are Christian Ivanov actually
called counter-revolutionary ethical
theory the theory based in the
grammatical fiction he calls it
Christian and humane one Christian image
that I've written about is that of the
pietá which is significantly developed
in the novel's opening scenes the Pieta
of course is an artistic image of the
dead Christ and it is not the only one
that brings to mind the biblical passion
very near the end of the book is a
passage I judge to be a flaw in a
passage that I judged to be a flaw a
geriatric janitor at the jail man named
vasily a dotard I'm not quite sure how
to pronounce this word I've just added
it to my vocabulary in recent days
following
the New York Times but here this one
this man is definitely either a doctor
or a dotard given to mumbling phrases
from the old Orthodox liturgy of his
childhood this man actually quotes an
extended scriptural passage from the
fifteenth chapter of the Gospel of Mark
linking the trial of Jesus before Pilate
with rubbish offs an administrative
hearing conducted by Glackin such
patterns may tempt us to miss prison
like Rubens like the rubbish off he so
brilliantly imagined Kesler it was a
classic intellectual european secular
Jew and a materialist what attracted
such man to communism was their belief
in explicable science and their
confidence that what Newton had done for
the laws of physics Marx had done for
the laws of economics it is true that
Kessler spent a good deal of his post
communist intellectual career on
projects that sought to expand the realm
of the material anticipating certain
current trends in evolutionary biology
and cognitive science among other things
but the idea of religious revelation
always seemed to him entirely
fantastical NS rubbish off who had a
shorter life than Arthur Kessler and the
slack time as well as the encouragement
for luxurious mental development
remain more primitive in his materialism
there's not the slightest whiff of
Atonement or expiation in his death the
brilliance of kessler's theory of the
Moscow trials a theory advanced not in
discursive argument but in the pages of
a historical novel is that it offers a
Marxist solution to a Marxist conundrum
the old Bolsheviks confessed not because
they were bad or weak Communists but
because they were such good and strong
ones Kessler sought and found an
explanation within the psychology of
Bolshevism itself he anticipated by more
than a decade the approach taken by
nathan light is and elsa burnout in the
more speculative parts of their
fascinating 1954 study of the trials
called ritual of liquidation the
defendants were Marxists in finist s--
that is not zero ist's and their view of
justice was a Marxist view in which
individual rights was a concept as
fictitious as that of the individual
himself what we call law was a
superstructure that like other super
structures could be demolished or
reconstructed in response to dialectical
necessity justice was what the party
defined as justice as like a meandering
stream that moved through history toward
its secular and material eschaton the
individual was nothing the collective
was all such people could concern
themselves with the truth or falsity of
the charges brought against them the
validity or fraudulence of the evidence
adduced only to the degree that they
elapsed from revolutionary into burgeois
and individualistic modes of thought
French communists did everything they
could to keep darkness at noon out of
the hands of their fellow Frenchman they
vilified its author they smeared its
publishers they picketed Advanta lies
book shops through labor unions under
party influence they even tried to
disrupt the actual its actual mechanical
mana fat manufacture their intellectuals
produce
a library of personal attacks Dyche
doctrinal refutations theoretical
execrations and fulmination x' but it
was all for naught Kessler's book
highlighted certain ideas which if not
in attica bold had at least not yet been
eradicated from the humanistic European
consciousness one of the two epigraphs
with which the novelist introduced his
book came from dostoevsky's Crime and
Punishment it is this man man one cannot
quite live without pity for Dostoevsky
this was a sentence written on the human
heart but it was not to be found in the
pages of Marx or Lenin thank you very
much
Thank You dr. Flemming we now have time
for a few questions please raise your
hand and a microphone will be brought to
you oh come on there's nothing more
awful you can do to a speaker well you
can fall asleep which some of you did
hand him the microphone please purpose
said there Daphne they translate us a
scientist titled doctors not known I
don't know why she did that but you said
you didn't know the meaning of it
anything to do with a solar eclipse or
something with that sort reminiscent of
it wait for the mic there is a line in
Samson's milton's samson agonistes that
is vaguely like this that's not the I
mean you study an author you get to know
the way he writes and he thinks and this
is not kessler's thing to ransack
concordance isn't so on the other
possible suggestion is of course the
trial of Jesus which I mentioned at the
end I mean as Christ is crucified there
is darkness at noon that is even less
appropriate for this book who wrote the
introduction that you're quoting him
wasn't me was it if it was me I am
willing to entertain the possibility
otherwise I do I declare it to be
rubbish
okay I don't know back in the 80s I ran
across Solzhenitsyn discussed this book
and he his position was is that it's way
over analyzed that it's really just a
non allegorical story about how a
revolution devours its revolutionaries
after the revolution is achieved and
that the real law that everybody was
being executed under was the idea that
the law was that they were guilty of
suspicion of having
counter-revolutionary thoughts and that
it's really just a simple story of how a
revolution disposes of its
revolutionaries you will find no greater
admirer of sultanate sand than me but i
do not rank him very high as a literary
critic if that's what he has to say
about darkness at noon it's rather like
what a famous whatever critic said about
Shakespeare's Othello it's the moral of
this play is that ladies often we have
to walked away after their handkerchiefs
does anybody here read that fellow I
mean daeviation ISM what deviation is a
man was deviating from the party line
and the party line that's not just a
metaphorical expression in the very
early days of the Politburo there was
some debate and you know people would
take votes and we decided by ten to
three that we're gonna do this but
Stalin had imposed upon them the
absolute necessity that all decisions be
unanimous
now you didn't get people voting against
the proposition but there were deviation
ISM the deviations that wrote the right
deviation s that is those especially
represented by Bou Karen and the 1938
trial were people who in general were
arguing that we ought to pay more
economic attention to the actual
consumer needs of our people rather than
putting all our attention to heavy heavy
industry the most famous right the left
deviation Ostrovsky who continued to
believe that the principle role of the
Communist Party was to lead worldwide
revolution in every country deadhorse I
have an interpretation of the title
which makes great sense to me perhaps to
no one else
darkness at noon would seem to mean it
is dark under communism it is dark even
at noon in other words under in a
communist world there is nothing but
darkness ok I'll put that up on the
board
hi there I'm Rachel and I was just
curious were there any other major works
or authors that influenced Kessler were
there any other major works or authors
who influenced Kessler Kessler was a
very widely read sort of you know good
Jim Jim nauseam education which meant
Eve he'd read a lot of different books I
would more say that he was a person who
influenced others they my own book
called anti communist manifesto
concentrates on four books which I chose
for a special with that one special
criterion in mind they had to be both
bestsellers and had to have been the
object of great strife and controversy
at the time in their publication this is
why Orwell is not one of them I mean
he's a great anti-communist writer but
he wasn't picketed and so forth way way
that Kessler was Crabbe chenkov wasn't
and and so on if you read darkness at
noon you will see many literary
allusions I see them to Dante I see them
to goethe's faust which almost any
person coming out of German literary
culture will have some of as Whittaker
Chambers does in witness protection
Bruges was very well read in German
German literature so I think of I think
of Caspar as a pioneer in the first
place and more as a person who
influenced everybody else
Crabbe chanko read Kessler john Felton
read Kessler Whittaker Chambers read
Kessler's became a personal friend of
his what was really brilliantly new
about it I mean nobody serious still
believed in the gills of the defendants
what was new is this extraordinary
suggestion that of a Marxist answer to
the Marxist problem Kessler's reported
death in 1983 I believe it was as a
joint suicide with his wife do you
attribute that to despair on his part or
a final recognition of the total
darkness he had been living in if you if
you are a student of literature one this
is one of the reasons I became a
medievalist is that I don't have to know
anything about the people I wrote I mean
I think Geoffrey Chaucer was a very
jovial person probably and and so is
Dante when I first got to Princeton two
of my very distinguished colleagues were
just beginning the definitive authorized
biography of two major American literary
figures very Frost was doing the Robert
very my friend one of my friends was
writing the biography of Robert Frost
and Carlos Baker was writing what became
Hemingway the life story to people that
they died alized
and I saw the same thing happened to
both of them that is about half way
through they realized that the people
they were writing about were such sons
of [ __ ] that
you know can I really you know continue
doing this now I greatly admire I very
greatly admire Arthur Kessler as a
writer and as a thinker I have grave
reservations about him as a moral actor
in person I believe that in fact he
coerced his wife into committing suicide
with him a wife who was in a fragile
psychological condition and so on that
is not the act of a moral giant as far
as I'm concerned but do as I say not as
I do a very good principal thank you for
your talk I'm wondering was this book
read in the Soviet Union did it make it
there and if so I guess what was the
result of it was not widely read in the
Soviet Union no the no the censorship
was as you probably know absolute some
later writers including Sultan itson did
develop a means of sort of handing
around surreptitiously foot were not
photocopied but made me a draft little
newspaper things with some of their
writings but nobody in the Soviet Union
read it until I would say recently
however his archive customers archive
which started out in Germany and was
then taken by the Red Army to Moscow is
still there so that anybody who wants to
write about him including his recent
biographer scandal had to go there
lemming has agreed to a book signing
at the end of this lecture in the lobby
of his book the anti-communist
manifestos and this will be our last
question
thank you for your talk I just wanted to
make a comment on another comment or I
mean no disrespect and maybe you could
comment on this also it seems to me Ruba
Schaaf is like is every one of us if we
were imprisoned under those kinds of
conditions inhumane brutal conditions
and it just seems like it just depicts
the breakdown of a human being and all
human beings within that prison and it's
just before the grace of God go I thank
you yes I think all great literature has
both a specific focus and a larger
penumbra of meeting meaning if this were
simply exhausted by the character
Rubinoff or even by the episode as a
polemical episode in modern political
history i think it would be less of a
book I've taught this book quite
frequently into undergraduates and I
love our undergraduates and they're
wonderful and so forth but
[Applause]
they they sometimes do tend to reveal
surprising cultural deficits such as not
having heard of World War two for
example now a lot of the stuff you teach
therefore you spend a lot of time sort
of oh you have to understand this and
once you go through a few of these
things who Stalin was who Trotsky was
what the trials were and so on
anybody can read this book and
understand as you say the deep
universality of it
I must comment however finally on this
book signing which has been thrust upon
me and had a certain sense unawares and
I will only make the comment that I do
hope that the first person in line will
be the librarian of this institution
because I went over to check on a
reference today just kidding here
[Applause]